hey everybody its Pete obviously firstly
I just wanted to acknowledge the fact
that some of the videos have been taken
down from the Pete Home Show I'm in the
middle of trying to figure that out
hopefully we'll be able to get some of
them back up and if I can they'll be on
this channel and I'm sorry for the
inconvenience it's inconvenient to me
because I like watching them too but in
the meantime there's some good news on
April 16th I'm coming to Chicago to tape
my new hour stand-up special at the Vic
Theatre and if you're in the Chicago
area it would mean so much if you guys
can come out to that because the better
audience the better the special so I
hope you guys can make it if you're out
in Chicago
April 16th Vic Theatre new our stand-up
special hope you can be there Pete
Holmes comm is where to get tickets for
that that's pretty obvious Pete Holmes
comm I'll also be doing some warm-up
sets in the California area before that
that week before if you want to come out
to that they'll also be on Pete Holmes
comm and that's it um how do you end
something like goodbye
jeez yeah that's me